اسمحوا لي أن أسألكم بالطبع رحب الرئيس بايدن
بإطلاق سراحها من السجن ، فقد جعل
حقوق الإنسان بندًا رئيسيًا من ركائز إدارته
أه أعاد أمريكا لتقدير
تلك القيم بالفعل والتصرف بناءً عليها
، لقد فعل أشياء بالفعل لإظهار أن
العلاقة الوثيقة في
ظل السابق  الإدارة مع
النظام السعودي
لن تستمر بالضرورة في ظل
إدارة بايدن
سواء كانت الحرب في اليمن سواء
كانت مبيعات أسلحة
وما شابه ذلك لماذا تعتقد
أه الحكومة السعودية أو أيا كان من
المحتمل
إطلاق سراح أختك في هذا الوقت
وأنه كان كذلك.  منذ حوالي أسبوع ،
نعم ، أعني أنها حقيقة أم أنها ليست
من قبيل الصدفة التي رأيناها أنه منذ
ما يقرب من ثلاث سنوات
كانت بالكاد تعقد أي جلسات محاكمة وفجأة
سئم كل شيء وحكموا
عليها بتعليق
الجملة ومنحها فترة
المراقبة ، لذا فإن كل شيء كان واضحًا تمامًا
لإدارة um mbs
تحت mbs بالطبع لقد تم حمايتهم من
قبل إدارة ترامب.
النائب نفسه
قال إنه أنقذ mbs
لذا أعتقد أنه من الواضح أنهم يشعرون
بالضغط وأعتقد أنه أمر
جيد أن
يضع بايدن حقوق الإنسان في صميم
علاقته بالمملكة العربية
السعودية ونريد أيضًا أن نشكره على ذلك
ولكن أيضًا
لا ننسى أن ريجين هي رمز
وكان أول شيء إطلاق سراحها ولكن
هناك
لم يتغير وضع حقوق الإنسان في المملكة العربية السعودية مع
إطلاق سراح روجاي وأعتقد أنه يتعين علينا
حقًا التأكيد على حقيقة
أنها أطلقت سراحها لكنها لم تتغير.  ليس حرًا
هناك ألف
سجين سياسي آخر في المملكة العربية السعودية ولا
يزال يتعين علينا الضغط من
أجل إطلاق سراح النشطاء الآخرين
والسجناء السياسيين من
أجل تحسين أوضاع حقوق الإنسان في المملكة العربية السعودية بالكامل
وعدم انتهاك حقوق الإنسان
مع الإفلات من العقاب.
لذا فأنت تشير إلى mbs وهو من الواضح أن
ولي العهد محمد بن سلمان الذي كان
يُنظر إليه على أنه
مصلح وهذا ما اعتقدته الإدارة الرابحة
التي تعرفها
أن هذا ما كان سيحدث.  س
سيحدث لكنك تقول
إن تمكين المرأة كذبة في
المملكة العربية السعودية ،
فلا توجد إصلاحات حقيقية ودعونا
لا ننسى أن
أختك كانت في طليعة المناضلين من
أجل حقوق المرأة
بما في ذلك الحق في القيادة
وهو ما
سمح به في الواقع وما زال يضعها.  في السجن
، فما هو الأمل الذي لدى النساء في
المملكة العربية السعودية
للإصلاح في ظل هذا أه في ظل هذا
السعودية
تحت هذا على mbs
آمل أن أظن أه عندما تكون
المرأة السعودية في السعودية
لا تستطيع إلا أن تعيش بالأمل  لذلك أعتقد أنه
ربما يكون البعض منهم متفائلاً ولكن
أعتقد أن معظمهم
الآن بعد أن
فهم معظم السعوديين أن mbs ليس مصلحًا
وأن وضعهم ليس أفضل تحت
mbs وأنك تعرف ما هو أسوأ من ذلك هو
أنهم لا يفعلون ذلك.  لا أعرف حتى أين
توجد خطوطهم الحمراء ، على سبيل المثال ،
فأنت تعلم أن بعض النساء قلن أنه حتى
يمكن للمرأة السفر دون موافقة
ولي أمرها الذكر ولكن في
نفس الوقت ما زلن غير مطيعات
و  قانون الاختفاء
الذي يعطي في الأساس أه
الحق لولي الأمر في القبض على ابنته
أو زوجته إذا
اعتبر أن السفر معصية
له أو
مختفياً ، لذا فإن النساء اللواتي ليس لهن
ولي أمر جيد
ليسوا أفضل حالاً تحت إم بي إس
ونعم كل الإصلاح  ما يسمى بالإصلاحات
التي يقوم بها هو أن يسعى الغرب
لإضفاء الشرعية على
نفسه للتظاهر بأنه
مصلح لكن
الحياة لم تتحسن حقوق المرأة في المملكة العربية السعودية في
الواقع
إنها نفسها تمامًا